depuis ce lundi 2 juillet deux nouveaux
visages ont intégré provisoirement les
rangs de la police de versailles morillo
maturi de rome et georges montésinos de
valladolid vont sillonner la cité royale
cet été ils sont parmi nous parce qu'il
existe un dispositif de coopération
renforcée en europe depuis 2008 qui
consiste donc à bénéficier de renforts
de policiers européens sur les sites qui
sont particulièrement touristique ou qui
accueille un événement festif culturel
sportif
leur mission patrouille avec les
effectifs français autour du château de
versailles pendant la journée
les deux policiers étrangers bilingue
auront pour principal objectif de venir
en aide aux touristes étrangers comme ça
avant de nous voir ils sont plus
rassurés et s'il arrive quelque chose il
vient me voir pour collaborer avec la
police
c'est toujours un aidant plus puisque
puisque la langue espagnole et on la
voit clairement sur le sur le parvis du
château donc cesser c'est une facilité
pour la communication pour tout type de
gestion
cet été deux autres gardiens de la paix
venus de l'étranger viendront garnir les
effectifs versailles et au mois d'août
un agent espagnole et une policière
allemande